foreign
for us mental health and emotional
health you're very careful to speak
about emotional health which I
appreciate
um what are the what's the Nuance there
well I mean I think
when we talk about mental health we're
typically talking about
diagnosable conditions and these are
things that obviously people are
familiar with you know depression
anxiety things of that nature but of
course it also includes more severe
conditions schizophrenia bipolar
hypomania or personality disorders you
know narcissistic personality disorder
borderline personality disorder these
things all probably fit somewhere under
the umbrella of mental health
um
emotion and and those are very
significant right so the prevalence of
these things within the population to
varying degrees is significant
um and there it's not necessarily always
to the point where it's pathological
right I mean a person can have some
anxiety and it not be a pathological
condition so
um
you know the system does tend to
pathologize these things a bit
I I'm I'm not I know nothing about that
system so there's nothing in you know
there's nothing I write about that
there's nothing I speak about there I
know nothing about that that is not my
field of training uh what I'm really
talking about is something that's a
little more Broad and something that
every person ought to be considering
which is emotional health and emotional
health
um well inclusive of mental health
should there be mental health issues is
probably a lot broader and it probably
includes
more it includes for example
um
happiness and joy fulfillment sense of
purpose
the state of one's relationships the
state of one's relationships not just
with others but with oneself
um
these things are probably the lattice
upon which
one really defines the quality of their
life in other words if if the State of
Affairs in emotional health is poor
it's hard to make up for it if not
impossible with anything else
um
like what you just said is really
powerful because we try to solve that
with infinite number of
charlatan hacks
and that's that's really important hacks
I mean I I think I think we we would all
try to solve those things we we would
all try to fill a void there with
other things that on the surface seem
reasonable work money success
um you know shallow friendships
um the approval of others you know
there's all sorts of things that we
would we we will try to use to fill a
void if there is indeed a void there and
um
I think if most people are being honest
and they think about it they realize
that
nothing else matters if that is in
disarray
um
and therefore I that's why I felt that
that at least warranted some discussion
in a book on longevity it feels like as
a mental health guy feels like a more
honest representation of what the
mental health Diagnostics are attempting
to do
which is paint a picture of an arc of
behavior or an arc of a body responding
but emotional health seems like a much
more honest way to look at it but again
it's hard to codify that into reimburse
for how much joy do you have versus how
many times have you felt anxious in the
last six months that's a
um
golly man I think that is Paradigm
reframing in a in a really powerful way
because if I'm seeking joy and I'm
seeking Beauty and I'm seeking happiness
and I'm seeking good relationships
that's going to impact movement and
sleep and metabolic health and eating
and also staying up too late and having
some beers when a buddy comes into town
it's going to impact all of that
as the I don't know that she feels like
window number one and not window number
after thought after you get all these
other things lined up
uh that's completely true
um so I think that those are those are
basically different sides of the same
coin so on the one hand
if that emotional house is not in order
for many people not for all but for many
people it becomes difficult to take care
of their physical health as well
and many of the behaviors that are
self-destructive to to one's physical
health whether it be with respect to
food exercise drugs
um anti-social behavior all these things
stem from
a breakdown in that emotional health uh
you know bucket and then similarly that
breakdown is also leading to just misery
so now you have
who are physical health and poor
emotional health but the core problem is
often the same
and and I guess the heartbreaking part
for me and I know you've sat with
countless patients just kneecap to
kneecap
is when the ticker tape running
underneath your life is
that you're worthless or you're a piece
of crap or it's your fault that your
parents fill in the blank
choosing misery is a it that makes sense
that's a deserved punishment for your
life and so there's almost
there's this really important need to
change some of those core messages so
that I believe I've got value Beyond
misery or I don't have a picture for
what non-misery life looks like my mom's
smoke my dad smoked my dad yelled my mom
left us every couple of weeks that's
just what I that's the picture I got
that's the that's the scale and being
able to paint a new picture that says
man there's there's
something else here it's just tough man
yeah and I I think it's I think it's all
of that and I think it's also
um believing that you can change the the
current state
um internally I mean right so so it's
it's one thing to think yeah I can get
out of this situation but a lot of times
you can escape one situation you find
yourself in a better place by external
metrics but the internal milieu is the
same
and I think that's the harder one to
confront and I think it's also the
harder one for people certainly for me
to believe that there's that there's
plasticity there that that thing can
change
there's been few scarier moments than
last year my wife and I sat on our front
porch out here we live on some Acres out
here in Nashville
overlooking our Dream we'd we'd we'd had
a financial year that neither of our
families just like family trees could
have imagined
and we just lost a friend our marriage
was pretty tough mate like it's tough to
think because I man I really hedge my
bets on these metrics and they didn't
like the amount of money in the account
and the amount of this it didn't come
through and it's harrowing a guy like me
thinking I got all the answers and I got
there and it wasn't there right what's
that old saying like I went with me
right I showed up there too and until I
deal with that guy there is no
there's no dollar amount that brings
peace to my home right